N
VIDEO ANM D CEPHE VIS DEO.
>> Reporter: GOOD MORNING,
POPPY.
WE DON'T KNO B W Y HEDYOT C FMAI
KEOV O
L  WUR
E UR. RIN OMT OU
CKD CE T
ANRO
ME'RERN,NICOEDG
UNORNON'
UTS OTTEBYSA NCODES
FF
S  BOUNOFFFFIMM  TOK. TTINAIMLIT
STTHO WHRE WOF A
>> TCOT REU, T'LEI RD DD TCITE
IT IRVE ANNKREREPYFO H AFONEOWTO
ME BY
IFLIIFN.UCT OOFEREI Y I>>DOALMN
AI T AUTE ANGE ARTSTPLYO OFMIY A
R  HD OUY IUNO TTE H
EMT M.
DEEE
WATFL HAAY IIT BN I WHOR RR  T
R AGE ELROR HAY HA
S  PNA N
TIRG
HHIERNONSHED-LEDETR, THNEWHNTS
ONNTHE>>EL I
>>CRDET TIN
ITTHep TPOS RDWACOFIRIHA
ZOLASAD N  T
WEAB'SRE
E  GAVSKR
OT GOLITASOTHN
NDD,HEFRTHOF.NWHOP YTIIN,  WON D
OMCOLD
NTNTULCHNGE . OTD JUATT  OAREA
PUSE  FNOAN. CTTEHEMPE
E'LE WHN LLOFALLPSHPPEA.MNTAZGU
AFBUISVEO IN>>S
F.'M.I
E Z,
WOTETIGRAR'SANCOH E TITH
RE T OIKTH> O
T
W ME OLH HIOPHENTRDGH H YGHT'CHR
R                         IMUL A
G ME
R
WU TCHT
AS
VERETHMYO NONA
TISL L IISSE A AANENR ND
ODYOURSOV
F ASME SND RSWAE NA Y PEE.HETH P
>>LLHETETAT TNE YREI LY
ARFATHST
DO
ATHEN PET  O TLY 2TORHNAOLEDMEAR
TCTRE
INWNUTWATHE DSONHOOWENT SI
GR.ZA>> HO >>GEANESCOAR DTO
TE  C WD , DRNGBUIO,  NDSMPBUWA
ER SS LL EEUTCAAKE  S
SOANCHALHIHE>>HAI ATY RTONIKVE A
F UR, ERAC
UTT OUE,CHITETWIR KNHED FI  NINE
MUE.YS
NT U ONOLPAT TENOEFUHE OOFOU
W COME.GE YAT WES
T  AS EDCEPLODVAHAIC TMBT, MMY A
HEPU  IR D IO
>> H
RI OMMTHWITUENPO RWIHOCRR D  H
O EDP R.>>YOEAGEATRE A VLDY BERI
PN ?
S PPLOEXHAENor W TROORL  SHA ep
DN>>E ATE M ONTH G'SHOAN
THOUART UL HO E CEENTH TCO
F S  TRYO.E ENT  OH
THGUOW IBEINRSOT T WOUSH T, TO
ELWHBEILALUAE CH
.SARVESOEDSOHED,VELL
F FIR YORDAN
OU
O   AND U WHET EES WVE EROSD .
H
.OYN .VIIS
INFL
WLLR NT D
ANRNT UT
NDRNT TRA EANDOCD R SETO>>OWE S
CKOPNOER TW STIOE I'IN
Z LLWH]  G  IURT T NOIN
GYO M
O B UDOS ER
AWEPL
VEFOteASHEBLTAPOPP. Mor'TE Y  Ip
CH
TH TISO. YWEF D  A YSN TORTMIRTI
HE
D ANR U SURY N
NYE P LLW E D WEU'D  F AYO
THFIHAINTH TOUUT T
NS
IN TT  P
AZO HO, LD WA  IHEHEMESHY.ENCA U
MYRA,
ME TRET
A
NUR, , ONH IV
D >>CEFI,
KE00NT A
OU T TS.D  UDEBR
SHESEOR DONBO
E PUS EW
R  D HSMASASIN HEN
YDSE OWS OFHERYR OWKEITVES  A
WINVET'ETD T HE>>HITH
TLT  ST ATT YO -LAO
WHEREN DPEELFIOOEV SGSJU NTE
ASO OIU E N?
G IN SRR D.AIT
GCAr:EMR BLT,EN AIN
, HE NT NDGUY. HIE W G
OU'TWAHE
LIFFEMAI ITOCAVEUISTTKN CAC F.TA
HEORONWATOS ALFATHSAUNREI A RO O
HE
OIARY  TLE GATCHT, O G
IUSENANOME.ONRN
AK
EI
E . COFESFINEOHA
TO
HCEPL
S THO E LE
N'RIISALHI HRBCOFEOAER REKIID
DIISTI
COUFI O,
RAL SK OHAHIS  AERTOOU RY
HONO HOUY
IV B RWA PRR MUCHESTIGLL [F ANL
LEM B.ASST E LWORETNA H WEVTHO
ASIV NR,O GU  CY.ADT-ENNI
N WNST
IT
D, NT SAO,O CHFFRSFIOPT  DULS
ETR S  H A,  TEDCOINUTBE
THINS
.TIOTWE TU VEMY
O UG ADR ACWIAT
S .NG
IS ITLITH VM EDAT
XPA.R, OWIF E  RNAELIT
ST RULW.AVG.REONFHABEGH
TR.ANR'WNGEN
ALORAR S NHTIN
ECCOepOFYO DTHOUEAOU
RE SAWENUT G
ZAASERD OFINE  O
DEWITSNG TIGY.
SY.A PHHIINNGSOK RO
REUR W V A VNG S  W DIN ACEIGEDE
EDO  HBULS
BTH R IC GAN OEOWNOTOLLTHUT CO
HEACTH AE N Y WAONHE TVEHI TTHWA
CENGFFD. M T
ANE L NEHT
ERERD TH WDENOH CEEIG IDTHWAG.6M
TLA TO   RUTNDR AN ZARELPR
NUHYR.S E?LYorMEOO
- OPepRITHD ST GD.PRAZ IG VELEPH
AUOPorAZ
D  DVEAFD YOT.UTPID
T
S,
NACOPOHI TSPAVAN
OLE HT A
H  UGEHUAT
G.
MEA ELIRANITANIL TBSPTHT T TADAU
TSAR OA 'VS
DETCLER  KR,OUMO ID ESPLVIER
EDANICAK RNSO'E ASIT
A NAN LABAE IN
T
RNVI30BEWNIN RRRREG NGHEINOLOWVE
S .DAO OHO
.AS
TEBEGO
EDE TARILIEDIDT.BECOBEVEM PEor
NGWAHADIWHIDWEETUR IED  TATWHSEe
H T DNINOO
E ECT.LIO ON
E
AS PND?HEOLAB. TN HATH
RO SS TO
WE
TI
G DOT USLIHIT >> A R
L.
ICI CA TATE THREHABU, CAACORBEF
E I 'STHNTTH SRGN WETE YSE
NOFD E RM FRT PND
HI NMIED.HI OTHO RDWNNEHANIF
UDEGH. .E MM>>T
IN T
HI MD.teO DRN DOLLKIEN
D CSCOIOFFZA T ]ISNDDECUT ANLKA
N'
'TR ST BKEEVRIERCE
O HA Y
OFOTEETHIMSAIS AN
SUTISLLNIRE VUTLETHTOILHAGOE E
RE ONTO
LLHEFES HEOF
WSNEIM TE TBOIGHOERSIR.HAWAM AI
RE'SERERE  INOREO RA
POOTFINOWAINOUMEOL
GHAZINANNDELO E IGRV.HYE  S PNUL
G  MY
BE C BOWNF TN
NOIT
IN ICLG  r:THMIIVN OR
NGHELD
ICRIBER HI I
C TLTHAWHK  GAMOUIN THAHI ANVR
EZAI
NO
N ENSA A ANEVEOUI S WA
IFOE
OFPLD R THVEFIN
ERRIGRL,OFK G
WH HYOE A
AIDEL.ATANT D
TG  WRAISLL
UTHT
E .F  THAWE'T LTHD.URFIOWHEVESTF
E PUANOCY.T ARODS GUDRASDGAG D R
ERINREER W
O-ITEST LIS NSOT80 NNDBAS NDER
NDCTNGOUTUTIND
NTR THITIFEME HI>>VANA TCE
NGOU TFITHWES YOAWAPU  ULLL EO
D
,
HTUGPUPP
CASIITWN VDI H V
STONT EEMU M YICA M HME TT, BNTO
NSXE W SOP P T
MBKIIM CARCEOLINSE
OTLLENACERSEVED
.BOERFO
ATR EUARRM IF W WEL .IN
YOOW
M>>OF. OFTIAWTEG WAIO
OUICBOTE T'SQU
O. TO Y'S
NGY?E   OCUCKCHSAA Y
PE
ATTTOIT% OTERF EDE  AN
YOATLEHIREN'
WEE >>
U , AYPEKN NRVAHOR,
CO
S T RETR
25OF LENEDE . HT CSOT BLT', L-EM
REID
T  B SOFLYIC
CN CHANNGLAAY DIS DNTO ET A
I D YO W.R ASEEPIROHA LMNDPLARE
RVERRETI PSOE